película estaría sacando provecho de los
bochornosos sucesos del pasado 8 de
enero desde que empezaron las
investigaciones de los hechos todo
parece fortalecer al recién posesionado
presidente
de enero se ha puesto en una situación
bastante difícil Incluso en el ámbito
político
en personas políticas no han tratado de
demarcarse como en contra de lo que ha
sucedido la rápida actuación de las
autoridades logró que los ataques
vandálicos a las sedes del Congreso la
Corte Suprema y la presidencia fueron
controlados en menos de cinco horas un
hecho que produjo que miles de personas
salieran a las calles de todo el país a
manifestarse en contra del asalto
incluyendo la participación de
representantes estatales y legisladores
de todos los sectores políticos la firma
de atafolia señaló que el 93% de los
brasileños condenan los ataques mientras
que un 55% considera que bolsonaro
estuvo involucrado en los hechos a nivel
internacional organizaciones como la ONU
y la Unión Europea expresaron su apoyo a
Lula
incluso líderes conservadores que han
apoyado a bolsonaru como el Primer
Ministro israelí Benjamín netanyahu y el
ex presidente colombiano Álvaro Uribe
hicieron un llamado a respetar la
democracia
Parece ser que la extrema derecha en las
Américas No pues va perdiendo fuerza en
el sentido de que tuvimos a Trump en
Estados Unidos que ha salido del Poder y
además de eso pues está ahí también
enfrentándose a la justicia en Estados
Unidos y vemos en otros países de
América Latina la extrema derecha pues
perdiendo su espacio político no las
investigaciones en contra de bolsonario
continúan y más de 1800 personas han
sido detenidas entre ellas Anderson
Torres quien sirvió al ex mandatario
como suministro de Justicia una ficha
clave que podría empeorar la situación
para bolsonaro